number three well the election is
basically over now folks i think i know
we haven't even had the debate yet
that's happening tomorrow but i think
this sort of seals the deal
for joe biden because the moment we've
been waiting for
has happened dwayne the rock johnson
has given his endorsement watch
happy sunday everybody we are
approximately five weeks away
from election day arguably the most
critical election
our country has seen in decades now that
said i'm going to be pushing this
political conversation
uh just a little bit more now you know
look i've got friends in all parties but
the one thing that we can always agree
on
is the conversation and the dialogue and
where that conversation
lands is always the most critical part
now this is something that i've
certainly not done in the past
so i'm gonna go big you guys know me if
i go
i go big so guys i had the opportunity
to sit down
with vice president joe biden and
senator kamala harris to talk about
a number of important issues that we're
facing as a country i thought it was a
great and
extremely productive conversation that
we had and
as a registered independent for years
now with
census centrist excuse me ideologies
i do feel that vice president biden and
senator harris
are the best choice to lead our country
and i am endorsing them to become
president
and vice president of our united states
okay now just a few a few quick points
if i may first look i'm in no position
to body shame
the rock uh he could quite clearly snap
me in half with his pinkies
i'm sure but at the same time i do feel
like the muscular physique gets a little
bit absurd at a certain point
doesn't it just you you cross through a
threshold at a certain point
where it's like okay dude just relax
take it down a notch take it i i get the
point just take it down a few notches
and i think the rock is teetering close
to that line it's it's a little much is
all i'm saying
that's it that's all i'm trying to say
um
second point probably more to the point
why did joe biden sit down with the rock
i mean and when did this have biden has
been working two hours
two hour days for the last like 19 weeks
he calls it a lid
on the day at 9 30 a.m most mornings
and yet he had time to meet with dwayne
the rock johnson
is that why he was calling a lid in
order to have extensive
meetings with the rock i'm imagining
five or six hour long meetings every day
for weeks on end
hashing out domestic policy foreign
policy everything with the rock that's
what i'm imagining
but as usual my imagination has no
connection to reality um
actually because we have the
conversation here's what the
conversation between the rock and joe
biden
really sounded like you guys are are
both obviously experienced to lead
you've done great things joe you've had
such an incredible career
you've led in my opinion with great
compassion and in
heart and drive but also
soul and you and i talked about that in
the past and how important soul is
and uh come live i'm going to embarrass
you just for a little bit because i'm
going to talk a little bit about your
uh your amazing experience and you have
been an attorney
a district attorney a state attorney a
u.s senator
smart tough i've seen you in those
hearings and
um in my opinion you are certified bad
ass
well he grilled them didn't he he really
he he held their feet to the fire
and but he was also definitely i hope
you noticed that he was definitely
reading
all of that information about camilla
harris
he was he didn't know anything about her
he was saying camilla
i know so much about you um i've always
been a huge supporter for your whole
career
in the um senate
yeah a big fan of camilla harris there i
mean but in fairness to him
and this is why i give him credit i
think he has a pretty good actor
to pretend that you're a big fan of
camilla harris
that's no easy task so that's probably
his greatest acting moment
i think was right there number four in
more celebrity news
singer john legend says that he and his
wife chrissy teigen might be
maybe are thinking of of maybe leaving
the united states if
donald trump is re-elected um now as
many have pointed out this seems like a
bit of an idle threat considering they
apparently just
bought a 17 million dollar mansion in in
beverly hills
not the kind of thing you do if you're
planning on fleeing a
country because it's become a fascist
wasteland in fact
not the kind of thing you could do
probably if it was a fascist wasteland
but besides that of course um you just
have to reflect on the
psychotic narcissism of these
celebrities
that they think it's some sort of
effective form of blackmail to threaten
to leave the country
as if we're all going to fall to the
ground grabbing at their feet like no
don't leave us please we can't we can't
go on without you
john legend i don't think anyone's going
to have that reaction
even if you're a fan of john legend what
do you care where he lives what
difference does it make it's a little
similar on a smaller scale it reminds me
of
the thing that people do to me online
all the time they probably it's a
comment they probably do it to you too
but on social media i get this kind of
thing all the time on a smaller scale
where
where someone will threaten to unfollow
me or un unfriend me
because i express an opinion they don't
like and my favorite is when they when
they say something like
you know i'm really thinking of
unfollowing you now matt i'm thinking of
it
this this opinion that's got me thinking
i might unfollow
and again it's as if i'm supposed to
break down in tears and plead with them
and say no
i'll change i promise don't leave me
it'll be different this time i promise
um we can go to counseling together no
just doesn't doesn't work the threat
doesn't work
nobody cares that much thank you for
tuning in to the daily wire one of the
fastest growing conservative media
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content